there is a guy named billboard Chris
he's up in Canada he shows up to these
crazy trans rallies and he wears a sign
he's got a very simple message says
children cannot
consent
that's it
he's not going so far as
I go in my speech when I say that
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely the whole
Preposterous ideology at every level
he's not going as far as everyone in
this country went before 2015 when we
did not tolerate transgenderism in
public life at all not in the bathrooms
not in the sports teams not nowhere
he's just saying children should not be
castrated sterilized butchered put on
cross-sex hormones should not be transd
and for that
he gets pummeled so it's power it is for
everybody all around you but probably
one so we honest you're bleeping it out
but here Fufu from all these
eccentric people holding all the trans
Flags the rainbow the baby blue and the
baby pink so a certain point they're
screaming so loudly in his face he just
starts videotaping them but then they
get really close I mean they're within
now a couple inches of his face and then
one of these dainty ladies with broad
shoulders and a huge Adam's apple one of
these dainty ladies just grabs him by
the throat and starts beating him up but
the craziest part of the video is there
are one two three four five six seven
eight nine at least nine or ten cops
there that's only what's in the frame
probably more and what do they do
pretty much nothing
they don't stop the transgender
identifying activists from shrieking in
this guy's face
spittle I'm certain landing on his face
they don't stop that and then the moment
that the the transvestite just starts
pummeling this dude they kind of they
start to walk toward it a little bit
it's kind of looking around they do
nothing
and of course if the roles were reversed
you know what would happen this would be
an international crisis
you know the cops would have been on
them like white on rice
but
the cops do nothing here
up in Canada it's like the Uvaldi
mounties same thing happened to Alex
Stein in New York Alex Stein the
conservative comedian he goes to a
transgender rally and he says kids
basically the same thing kids can
consent you shouldn't trans the kids
you're sterilizing kids that's wrong to
do he's getting hot coffee thrown on him
he's getting beaten up he's being
grabbed and thrown around luckily he's a
pretty big guy and what does the NYPD do
nothing and I don't even think it's the
cops fault most New York cops I know are
pretty normal people they're pretty
pretty regular guys who don't think that
men or women and women are men I'm sure
they're just getting political orders
from the top saying if a normal person
attacks a transgender identifying
activist throw the book at him but if
the transgender identifying activists
attacks the normal person look the other
way
that's obviously what's going on we know
that's how our justice system works
because our justice system says
if a granny takes some selfies in the
capital rotunda on January 6th throw her
in solitary confinement but if BLM burns
the country down for eight months let
him off the hook
huge number of BLM Riot cases in
Manhattan in the Bronx all around New
York were just totally dismissed they
didn't even get a slap on the wrist
this is not a nation of laws this is mob
violence you saw the mob down in Texas
there was a a rally among the
transgender activists in Texas to to
stop Texas legislators from from
prohibiting the transgender Butchery on
little kids and
the the mob started shrieking just days
after that shooting where a transgender
identifying shooter targeted a Christian
school and killed little kids and their
teachers the the transgender activists
lie down in the hallway of this protest
to pretend to be dead they completely
flipped the script and here's how they
sound here's their really brilliant
articulate argument
look at the eyes
you can always it's always the eyes you
can tell
there is something weird here going on
yeah and they're all focused on the
person filming shrieking screaming
middle fingers up
trans kids
and when I was watching this clip all I
could hear was
you see these people just lying around
on the ground pretending to be dead
totally flipping the script of what
happened
but all all I could hear when I saw this
clip
was
give us Barabbas that's all I could hear
I I know that's not what they were
literally saying but I thought this
is the way mobs always work some people
are incredulous that the mob would
behave this way
this is what mobs do
mobs murder people who speak the truth
and they crucify the truth himself
it has ever been thus
they make they make people drink Hemlock
they crucify the truth
this is it and so what are they talking
about here they're talking about trans
kids trans kids are the new democrat
Idol it's the new golden calf trans kids
that's the new democrat Idol that's the
new golden calf
this Democrat Idol is every bit as
Fantastical as the golden calf
and like the golden calf
this Democrat Idol involves child
sacrifice
what is the trans kid what is meant by
the trans kid what they mean is
children who were born into the wrong
body so it's children little boys but
they're really little girls really
somehow somewhere they're really little
girls but they're in the wrong body
and that's why we need to allow people
like Jeffrey Marsh and Dylan Mulvaney
and and the the drag queens of drag
queen Story Hour with criminal records
to go and and help these children to
come into their true selves by jiggling
around in front of them and presenting
them with gay porn like genderqueer by
Maya kababi and that will help them
become their true selves
but of course none of that is true
because it is not possible to be born
into the wrong body it is not possible
to be a man in body but a woman in not
body in spirit in Soul metaphysically
that's not possible
that's imaginary
that's the ideology of transgenderism
but the ideology of transgenderism is
wrong
and so the category of trans kid is an
illusion
certainly there can be children who are
confused about their sex and gender uh I
think that's true of many people when
they're going through puberty because
they're having so many changes to their
body which is which impels a lot of this
confusion that the Democrats are
exploiting to permanently sterilize
these kids but that can be people can
suffer confusion from their sex for all
sorts of different reasons if they've
been sexually abused that's a cause of a
lot of this sort of sexual confusion
a lot a lot of other issues contribute
to this that's all real the confusion
can be real but
the the category of transgender kid is
not real
that is an idol established by the
Democrats
Liberals by the radicals by the leftists
called whatever you want to call them
and that's the new one that's the one
they're going to focus on that's their
new object of worship
and their objects of worship going back
to the pagans of old somehow always come
down to child sacrifice and in this case
the worship is the child sacrifice it's
abusing the children it's butchering the
children it's castrating the children
it's all of the above it is it is uh
encouraging them to adopt an ideology
that has a huge correlation with
suicidality talk about child sacrifice
it's
sick Pagan demonic evil
and it was unfortunately ever thus we
we've done a good job at various times
in our history at suppressing this kind
of movements but as religiosity has
declined as the prayer has gone out of
schools as Church 10s has declined these
Pagan practices crop up again
it's music Monday Baby the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Noel
skin of wlas a checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you